As an app developer,
you don't think of monetization at
the end of when you build the app.
You should really be thinking
monetization when you first are thinking
about building your app.
I met this amazing app developer
in the Bay Area who built a game.
And he came to talk to us recently,
and he said, you know,
I have to start all over again.
We were kind of scratching our heads.
We said, why?
He said,
I never thought about building
the breaks inside the game for
where an ad would actually sit.
He's like I have to kind of
start over and think about okay.
You know, where, maybe in this level,
I'll put one here.
And maybe, during where it
shows the scores and all that.
So, he had to actually go back and
redo his game which was unfortunate.
But, it just shows you that, when you
are thinking about monetization, or
even just building your app in the first
place, think about the future.
Don't think about right then and there.
Think about what you really want to
get out of your app in the long term.